so why kickstarter now why not why now
because it's the right time for me and
movies are continuing
to become devalued they're continuing to
lose value
a lot of movies have zero value and i
and that's
despite all the hard work going into
them despite all the passion
and everyone that showed up on set at
the end of the day the finished product
has no value except for
the people that can say i did this and
that is maybe enough but as far as
building a career you have to figure out
a way
to assign some value to your work
whether that
transitions into exposure money or
whatever because let's face it the big
commercial studio movies are just crush
everyone because it's what everyone
what we're exposed to what we where we
know to see when we drive past the movie
theater that's what's playing
so unless you can find you know
independent films
it's it's like people go into them
knowing they're gonna lose money
you know unless you make a movie that
wins sundance or something they don't
distributors aren't paying any money for
movies it's all profit sharing it's all
give us your movie you know give us give
us the whole pie and we're going to cut
it up and serve it to a few people if it
tastes good
they're going to give us some money and
then we get to filter you know
you relying on them to be honest and
they're accounting and
it's all profit sharing you know
so it's not like it was you know i
wasn't even around
doing this in the 90s when apparently
independent films flourishing and people
were paying money
for these dvds and home video and it was
you know you could actually make a movie
and have it make over a million dollars
that doesn't happen i don't think
anymore there's no one's getting
advances i just made a movie with movie
stars in it
you know guy from you know kerry always
from the princess bride
you know who cares
it's a great performance we have great
actors but
no one's spending money on movies
anymore and the studios have figured out
a way to monopolize it
and the reason i went to kickstarter is
because
i can get financing and
it's money that i don't have to recoup
you know um and and
in exchange for that money they get
something out of it whether it's a dvd
you know it's the whole reward tier
system
but i think there's a downside because i
think a lot of projects on kickstarter
again speaking as a novice i haven't
been on there forever
they get their goal and they fail to
deliver they fail to fulfill
and again that's another black eye for
kickstarter